[Music]
on today's show we talked to a
father and husband who's trying to
navigate his wife
and his mother we also talked to a
father he's got a 16 year old son who's
brilliant
but he thinks he might be lazy we also
read your letters
stay tuned
[Music]
hey everybody what's up this is john
with the dr
john deloney's show and i
started the show with a growl because
that makes me sound tough
right i'm so glad you're with us
[Music]
on this tough show about mental health
and relationships
i think i'm the least tough guy that i
know especially when i'm in a room with
kelly
and james i am the least tough of the
three
hey and uh we're glad to have everybody
back we got a full deck
now and james was so unimpressed
with ben he's making ben sit behind him
now it's so good and just watch
don't speak ben just watch
don't speak that's a great no doubt
reference shout out james i appreciate
what you did there that was huge
if you don't know who no doubt is just
pause this right now
and go to spotify and go through the top
three or four
no just listen to tragic kingdom in its
entirety start to finish
and then you can come back to this
podcast hey man
y'all doing well fantastic ben's nodding
not speaking to you ben just kidding i
am glad to see you
glad to see everybody back to look
everybody man um hey we got a wild show
today so i'm excited y'all are here
and so i'm gonna get right to the phones
and hang with us on this show cause
we're gonna
have some really cool letters that have
come in that i want to walk everybody
through
and they're they're powerful they're
great and i want to get to aaron
um aaron is with us from seattle
washington and aaron
you were on the show the other day and
the way this works
is kelly puts the calls up in an order
and they're color coded and i just
screwed it up
and i went to the wrong color and that
meant i got
out of order and then you had to go to
work
yeah yeah that's right because evidently
making money or whatever is more
important than being on this show which
is ridiculous but whatever aaron
no man i'm so sorry brother i screwed up
dude i'm sorry
no that's all good it was it was more
that uh driving
to work i i entered uh some roaming
areas so do not roam and be on this show
it's just not worth you paying for this
stuff
for sure this is this is a free
transaction
absolutely man hey how can i help dude
good to talk to you
thanks for taking my call dr dalonia i
really appreciate it
um i i'm i am having some
trouble uh navigating
how to choose my wife and honor my
mother um
yeah tell me more about that yeah so
seems like you can do both of those what
am i missing
sorry um about um
uh about sorry one second
about three years ago uh my my father
passed away
from a rare degenerative brain disease
um we all had seasons of caring for him
but you know my mom really took care of
him until the end and
um after that my wife and i made a real
conscious
effort to um to to be there for her
to to you know have her come out to
visit
and um you know fast forward to
today and and my mom she really wears
a lot of that neediness on her sleeve
and and it just feels like
you know nothing can ever be enough and
it can be really abrasive
especially for my wife who isn't used to
you know personality quirks and and
whatnot and so
um the the trouble comes
when i find myself
defending my
mom's intentions over my wife's or
advocating for her and
my wife has felt really hurt by the way
that i've handled
um this relationship and i just i don't
i don't know how to do those two things
well
dude thanks for thanks for trusting me
with that um
is your wife right like just being
honest just two guys is your wife right
yes yeah she's she's yeah have you told
her
you're right and i'm sorry and i don't
know what to do
um yes okay and she she's asked me to
talk to people
so so backing up to your mom she lost
her husband she lost her co-pilot
and sounds like it was a
long slow burn which is a really painful
way to see somebody go
and in the meantime a lot of people
rallied around her
is that right um
no not so much i feel like with the long
slow burns
people don't know how to
people don't know how like you know how
long do i bring this up for you know
uh they just don't know how to be around
uncomfortable situations where you're
or where the other person's in diapers
and the other person's bedridden and you
so no i didn't feel like a lot of people
rallied around
in the heat of that situation there's
one or two that
stick around and you know that they're a
good friend but yeah
so fast forward a couple of years this
is several years ago
when you say she's you've got to
apologize for she's
not being um she's not pleasant she's
got
anytime a son says my mom's got
personality quirks that means
mom's not being cool and you're trying
to find a nice respectable way to say
like my mom's really hard to be around
so when you say she's got quirks
she's tough you have to apologize and
explain what does that mean give me some
give me some examples
yeah so it's it's mostly in it's in
moments where
um my wife and my mother um
don't get along and um it it really does
seem like
like personality clashes where um
my my mom is actually a really
kind of cheery in-your-face person
loud and um and
her and my wife just don't don't get
along and so when it comes to things
like
how often should she visit or how long
or where should she stay
uh you know my wife is um
she draws these pretty heavy boundaries
um
it's not just personality differences
it's my wife
um or sorry my my my wife has drawn
these boundaries and she feels like my
mom
continues to cross them so this doesn't
sound like
grief issues and so
one common misconception is people who
are grieving deeply can be
jerks too right
that doesn't i thought that's what this
call was that doesn't sound like that
that sounds like your mom wants to come
visit and hang out and your
wife doesn't like your mom and so she
says mom can't stay here i don't want
mom around
is that is that more the issue yeah yeah
i think i was i was equating the grief
with
neediness um and
we have the monopoly on grandchildren
right now and so she always wants to
come and visit the grandkids and
so why doesn't your wife like your mom
because she's cheery
i see so i thought this call was i
thought you were calling to say my mom
is constantly calling us and crying and
you don't care about me and why do you
love her over
me and you just abandoned me and i'm
still grieving like
that doesn't sound like the case sounds
like mom just wants to is lonely
and she wants to come hang out with
grandkids even if she's not lonely she
once comes to your grandkids wants to
come see you guys
and your wife doesn't like her why why
doesn't she like her
yeah um so for for a couple years
that was the case that that my wife
really didn't
didn't feel like she liked my mom she
she had said that and
she's recently had a change of heart and
and
she kind of recognized that my mom isn't
necessarily a problem
but it's when there
are relational issues when there
are um boundaries crossed because
i have been quick to defend my mom
my wife doesn't feel like she can be
totally transparent with me and she
doesn't feel like she can bring
to me oh you know your mom did this
this really annoying thing with the kids
and
and you know this thing i really didn't
like or she fed him
this thing and so aaron feel like she
can aaron your mom's not the problem
you and your wife are having some
challenges right
yes yeah yes mom has become a
cool easy outside target for your wife
because she doesn't know how to deal
with you
yeah well i i feel it's you know me
um what is it man there's something
bigger that you're not telling me
like what what is the relational
fracture between you and your wife
you've got little kids you're exhausted
you're not showing up
your wife has changed like what what is
it there's something bigger than mom
um
yeah i i i've kind of
felt like they were unrelated
um you know i i just felt like it's
kind of this um
my tendency to um defend my mom
and um it's not man your mom has become
a way that your wife can try to talk to
you
without attacking you
and so that that's your sounds like it's
your wife
trying to get your attention without
coming after you do you take feedback
well
or do you shut down are you a shutdown
guy
um you think i've become a
shutdown guy okay if your wife gets
pissed at you
do you go into neutral do you fight back
like what do you what's your response
there
i go into neutral okay
so your wife knows i can't talk to you i
can't comment you i can't
have a healthy fight with you i can't
have conflict with you so we can work
through it
because you go into neutral and tell me
i go after mom yeah
and you're there probably is some real
hurt
whether it's um justified or not
right you lost your dad and that's hard
how long have you all been married
uh five years yeah man so learning how
someone you love
grieves is always messy it's always
messy
my wife and i had to deal with that too
uh she lost a really close family member
a couple years after we got married
i didn't get it i didn't understand it i
grieved differently
i thought she was grieving too hard i
didn't know what i know now and so we
had to learn how each other grieves and
there was some pain associated with that
she thought i was insensitive and she
was right and i thought she was
so we had to figure that out you you
had the misfortune and the heartbreak
and the challenge of you got married and
then a couple years in
um your dad's body began to shut down on
him and then he passed away
and y'all are still figuring out
marriage figuring out young kids and now
you're figuring out how to grief
and by the way my mom's grieving too so
you're in the middle of this thing right
so
that's something that every young couple
has to work out that's part of it but
there's something bigger here
whether you haven't dealt with your dad
whether you haven't dealt with
i don't think i like my wife because she
was mean to me when i was hurting
whatever that is
you all have got some major relational
fractures that i'm worried about and
then your poor mom is just what's coming
out of their grandkids
and she's become the the
scapegoat here so let me ask you this do
you love your wife
i do do you like her there's a
difference there
yeah i i feel like 90
of the time it's it's wonderful and and
then
we hit these ruts and for
you know a month or so we don't like
each other
are you a when you go into neutral
let me ask it this way are you violent
with your silence
yes do you become a very heavy presence
in your house
yeah i do and you'd never hit her or
scream at her
but you'll just slowly drown the house
in that
i my wife calls it sunday afternoon dad
but just that
hulking you know what i mean
yeah yep yeah that's me yeah
so don't do that man don't drown your
wife
in silence and
y'all are in desperate need and i'm
telling you this from personal
experience man
i did this for 10 years 15 years i got
so self-righteous
i would never scream i don't yell i
don't smash stuff
i don't fill in the blank i would never
be abusive i don't raise my voice
but dude i could just
be violent with silence and avoidance
and whatever then fine and yeah
i left my wife out there on an island
screaming and yelling and waving flags
saying will you help me
will you talk to me nope cool man
whatever dude you know what i mean
so here's what y'all are desperate nita
how old are your little kids
uh we've got three in three years
good gosh dude yes of course
so just back up for a second the last
five years by the way if you ever call
somebody else for help lead with that by
the way
you've got did i have that i have three
kids in three years yes
in a five-year-old marriage and by the
way dad slowly died
in this process and then my mom
slowly grieved drowned with it drowned
she drowned with him
and then stuck her hand up and i was the
guy
you guys have had a lot in five years a
lot
yeah yeah y'all are exhausted you're
fried out
y'all used to just go be silly and
reckless and i bet you used to be fun is
my guess
i bet you were a blast i was a blast for
sure
and your wife remembers that guy yeah
and are you all like deep and thoughtful
and you're like oh what about this and
you got like thoughts on bitcoin and
stuff is that you
surprisingly accurate i knew it and i
bet your wife
you see look that's the guy she married
and here's the thing
that's the guy you are and you've heard
me say this a hundred times i'm gonna
say it a thousand times more until they
take the show off the year
but listen you all gotta get away
and you gotta just look your wife in the
eye and say i have sucked and i'm sorry
now to my defense dad died we got three
kids i love you
but this has been chaos and i haven't
done this right
and we cannot go back and edit yesterday
all we can do is hold this pen and start
writing new sentences for tomorrow
and it's going to start with excavating
the site you've heard my twin towers
analogy you cannot take
what's happening is you're waiting for
things to get back to the way they used
to be
and she's waiting for things to get back
to the way they used to be and you can't
because
there is no going back you got three
kids under three
you all are on the annual sex plan and
every time you do it you have a kid
right it's a little better than that but
yes
it's not you can it's just america it's
they're fine they get it too
they're all there too but listen you all
have to have to get away and look at
each other and say
i am still in and i've got a lot of
growing to do i've got a lot of
apologizing to do i've got a lot of
saying i'm sorry and i need to learn
some new skills and she does too
the mom isn't the issue y'all are
exhausted and fried and cooked
you cannot take all that metal and all
that glass and
all of the smoke and dust and rebuild
the twin towers
you can't you got to excavate the whole
site get a new architect get new
engineers
dream big and then rebuild something new
and it's going to
suck aaron it's going to be hard but
here's the deal
right now sucks and it's hard isn't it
yeah
yes so choose the hard choose the
the difficult path that is fun and
romantic and has sex
and laughs a lot and listens to music
and your stupid theories on bitcoin and
whatever
um go back to that or create something
new don't go back create something new
to that
dance in your living room man decide
that you're going to love this woman
and then there's going to be moments
when your mom wants to come visit
and then you need to talk to your wife
about hey
mom needs to see your grandkids that's a
thing that's going to happen
i turn into an idiot help me
be a better husband when my mom is here
what do you need from me
and i guarantee you she's got a list
that's different than
well mom this and how can i honor you
when my mom is here and then you're
gonna go tell your mom
that and your mom is gonna think you're
the greatest husband ever
wow and my mom i mean my mom my wife
sends emails to our family hey here's
the schedule here's who's sleeping where
and that helps everybody's there and we
love it right but it's just negotiating
and learning and talking to each other
and i will be honest with you brother
your marriage is on the ropes these are
tough tough seasons
so this is sos time the alarms are going
off
um you step into the gap here man
start with i'm sorry stop what i've
blown it stop start with
we're gonna rebuild this thing dude i'm
so
excited for what this is gonna turn into
i want you to call me back after you
have this conversation with her
you're gonna take her out we're gonna do
a half day retreat you and her
hey can i chime in with something yeah
yeah what if there are legit
boundary issues with mom that that are
being crossed as well
so if so this aaron this is james so if
there are legit boundary
issues you have to have the boundary
conversation with your spouse a great
question james you got to have the
boundary conversation with your spouse
outside of all this other stuff so a
part of
i'm all in i haven't been doing my end
right and she's going to say
i haven't either and we're going to
clean up the way we talk to each other
clean up the way our marriage looks like
then we're going to have a true boundary
conversation so the way i like to think
about that is
you can't build fence on lava on moving
rock you've got to let that stuff
be settled and then you can say here is
our boundaries
and then you have to communicate those
boundaries to mom
right and sometimes that boundary might
be hey mom we have a house
that's small it's a three-bedroom
two-bath house and we have three kids
under three
that all need to sleep they all need to
have these a solid routine
plus me and my wife plus plus plus we
need you to stay in a hotel we're gonna
pay for the first night you can stay as
long as you want we want you here at 8
am to come play but
here's our nap times we don't budge on
these we do
not feed our kid these things we're
asking you
i'm asking you as your son to honor that
oh honey they can have twinkies
not in my house right and there comes a
moment when if mom crosses those
boundaries that's a whole separate phone
call it's a whole separate conversation
um and there may be a moment when you
say you can't be on the kids because
we've asked you and you're not honoring
our boundaries
i don't think that's the case here but
yeah it's a great question james but i
don't want people building boundaries
because what happens is you end up
building boundaries
against your spouse to punish your
spouse not because of
a mom issue right great question ma'am
look at that question in a question this
is like a russian doll episode here i
love it yeah it's an enemy of one of
those two things can be true at the same
time it's exactly right situations
but you gotta go you gotta make sure
your your relationship is healthy first
and then start
building battery so you gotta make sure
your ground is stable before you start
putting fences up right
hey thank you so much for that call
aaron call me back after your half day
with you with your wife
i gotta know how it goes um my gut tells
me it's gonna go great
and maybe i'll just take a half day
you'll meet for two hours then i'll just
go take a nap for a couple of three
hours
that would be awesome all right hey stay
tuned we'll be right back with the dr
john delaney show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that
everyone has anxiety i've been there and
so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole
and well listen you are not broken
and i'm living proof that you can get
your life back
i wrote this book so everyone could read
it not just science nerds like me and my
friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
all right we're back hey listen
five bucks to kelly i'm so s james can
we just edit that out i hate doing that
nope you're just gonna make it right
sometimes you just gotta own up
so far i'm gonna get something pretty
nice here pretty soon you are
you're gonna get something pretty nice
uh
for those of you new to the show i
always
say hey listen and y'all are sitting
there with the headphones on and you're
in your car you're already listening
clearly
and i'm telling you hey listen so dumb
directing y'all what to do y'all are
growing up you can do whatever you want
um a few episodes ago
i don't know maybe 20 or 30. it's
talking about
these stories we tell ourselves right
these things that we happen that we
carry around with us like bricks in our
backpack
and i offered folks this
write these things down what are the
stories you tell yourself
write them down demand evidence from
these things and then put
them down and put them down means
different things for different people
some people write letters and they burn
them some people i had a client once
that
wrote letters and they shot it up with
one of his ppu guns or whatever
but i offer people hey send them to me
just put them in the mail and be
done with it have a spiritual moment
have a
existential putting these stuff in the
mail write them down and
let them go and i got letters man and
hey the offer still stands
you got something that you cannot get
out of your soul
that you wake up anxious you go to bed
and your heart's racing you wake up at 2
a.m
and you're thinking about this thing
that happened thinking about things that
you did
the things that you said that you can't
go back and change or 10 years ago 20
years ago 5 years ago
the things that happened to you things
that happen to somebody you love
at some point you have to make the
decision i'm not going to be defined by
the worst thing that ever happened to me
i'm not going to be defined by the worst
thing i ever did
and i've got to decide i want to be a
part of a healing process
this one take a different road and it
starts with taking the bricks out of
your backpack and setting them down
you're welcome to mail them to me use a
pen
on a piece of paper and write them down
and mail them so i got letters man
and some of these were gut wrenching and
hard and beautiful
i just picked two this morning um
there's i mean the number like this
here's one and and these are heavy i
want you just to know that they're heavy
um some of these had no names on them no
return addresses on them they just came
to me at work i didn't know where they
were from
um that sometimes they had a postmark
city but sometimes you know i don't know
if they're actually mailing if they're
on vacation or whatever but here's one i
got
um close your eyes and listen to this
letter
my name is xyz and i'm a huge fan of
your show
your positivity and compassion is
infectious makes my day better hope it's
making
me better thanks man i heard on your
show that you told someone to send you a
letter with the word cheater on it
as a way of letting that go and i was
planning on doing something similar but
burning it and i figured i'd just send
it your way
so here's my situation and this person
actually sent two letters one to me and
one to the
person that hurt them
so here's my situation and what the
other letter will be
tomorrow i'll be asking the parents of
the most wonderful sweet
tough bubbly and lovely girl for their
blessing to marry their daughter
there is one chapter of her past i still
haven't gotten over and will hopefully
finish in premarital counseling
in her previous relationship she was
pushed under physical boundaries and was
raped
she's processed it forgiven the guy that
hasn't even asked for forgiveness
and considers it part of a plan she's
thankful for chances she gets to use it
as a way to connect and help others
she's moved completely past it but i
still hold resentment towards this guy
uh-huh i don't want him to occupy my
thoughts or energy anymore so attached
is my letter to him
i hope you get this and maybe speak
about being in relationships with people
who've had an abusive past
and he goes on to write a letter to that
guy
fortitude to be able to look in the
mirror and say i'm letting somebody that
i've never
met but that it hurt the woman i'm gonna
spend the rest of my life with
and i gotta let that go
because all i'm gonna do hanging on to
that is i'm just gonna
drown the current relationship i'm in
and the letter that he wrote
is as gut-wrenching and heartbreaking as
you can imagine
but it's powerful and so if you're
listening to the show and that's your
letter i want to tell you thank you as
an honor that you sent that to me and
you trusted me with that
i think you're a brave stud
for saying hey i'm putting this down and
i'll tell you this is going to be a
healing process
you say my wife's over it this will
circle back and there'll be some
challenges but she's got a
rock star by her side who understands
hey
you were hurt somebody somebody
took a lot from you and i love you
and we're gonna be in this together
moving forward
thanks for sending that man and thanks
for being strong enough to say i'm gonna
set this down
another letter we got um
no name man
just says in giant marker
no more second guessing
and underneath it in pen it writes i
don't need to second guess
every decision i've made
it is what it is he left me here and
when he did he left
all the joy and happiness and
opportunity
to be healed he left us with a quiet
joyous peaceful home he left me with a
safe
calm place to raise mine our children
where they don't wait for the next shoe
to drop
i couldn't make him stop yelling make
him happy enough
i couldn't make him be here long enough
to just enjoy our beautiful lives
together there are things i miss
and i'd never imagined for this for
myself or my family
but when i step back and really look at
what he gave us by finding himself a
better life
i have no doubt in my mind i'm doing the
best i can
that i gave everything i had to that 21
year marriage
and i loved him and i loved our kids
i'm still trying to prove myself i'm
still trying to
show i can run a household and pay the
mortgage and all the bills and provide a
wonderful environment for myself
and my kids all without any support from
him
he never even asks if they need anything
but that's the way it is
i know this and i don't fight it
i just continually readjust the sails of
my boat
pointing towards my north star
no more second guessing
after 21 years he just looked at her and
said
i'm out good luck with kids
man that's hard hard hard
and yet she says i'm learning how to do
this and it's a grind and it's tough
and it's painful and i second-guess
myself but i'm putting it down
i can't go back and change him can't go
back and change those 21 years i can't
go back and edit the past but i can
write a new tomorrow
i don't know who sent it i don't know
where it's from but i want to tell you
if you're listening
what an honor you're a strong
powerful extraordinary woman
find a community that will rally around
you let people
support you so you can get some sleep
and some rest
man your kids are lucky to have you
awesome
hey send me your letters that stuff
you're carrying around those stories you
tell yourself those stories you were
told growing up
those stories you're told at work still
write them in a letter put them in the
mailbox set them down be done with it
thank y'all for being brave all right
let's take another call let's go to
andrew in indianapolis hey andrew what's
up man how we doing
dr john how we doing today buddy we're
all right brother how about you
oh no not too bad not too bad
outstanding man
what's up i uh i have a almost 16 year
old son
he's uh he'd be 16 next month he's uh
autistic and he's high functioning
autistic which means
someday he'll have to get a job have a
family
and be a productive member of society
okay um and anybody who has all
uh some with autism or daughter with
autism knows that
um even though high functioning autistic
people
can definitely function in society they
definitely have some quirks about them
sure um and he is i want to say lazy i
don't know if that's the right word
okay his iq is off the charts he's super
smart
unlimited potential yeah but just will
not
get out of bed will not get a job while
not has no desire
to be a member of society and i just
wanted to know if
if you've had people like that if you've
ever heard of such a situation
and what advice you would give them yeah
i've heard i've heard it with both
first man thanks for
i say thanks a lot on this show but
here's the thing man
there's not a lot of dads that will say
hey i'm trying my best on my son you got
some you got some ideas
so many dads just try to bury that thing
and grind it out with the way their
dad's
dealt with them so thanks man thanks for
being willing to ask
i'm i'll tell you what john my my dad
was a
marine was uh there you go great
depression
yeah um so for me it was always just
sucking up buttercup
you know right get work done and that's
kind of how i've tried to raise him and
it
it's not working yeah oh man
so hey well thanks for calling man so
i do hear this a lot very common but i
hear it from
parents who've got autistic 16 year olds
and parents who have
regular 16 year olds right so
you're not bananas and out of the
ordinary anything like that
um how is your son with emotional
regulation so you have a good grasp on
it and here's why i'm asking that
a lot of 16 year old kids 17 18 19 even
20 21 year olds
they struggle autistic kids they
struggle with the emotional regulation
and that exhaustion doesn't look
physical it looks lazy and
that social anxiety and that build up
that i don't get these social cues
it's kind of like you if you walked into
a restaurant and everyone's speaking a
different language than you
and they're all trying to talk to you
and everyone's getting louder and more
frustrated with you
the easiest thing for you just to leave
right it's going to leave
um and so when it comes to that
emotional regulation and everybody's
like eyebrows and clicking and
smiling and not smiling and turning
their heads it just becomes a lot and
dude i'm just going to go lay down
that means so how is he with emotional
regulation
i think you just described him to a t
okay um
he hides in his bedroom a lot because he
doesn't
do you know deal with people very well
he
uh he has the maturity of a much much
younger person
uh but yet he's he's like i said he's
extremely smart
he can build a rocket ship someday yeah
yeah yeah
so we live in a culture that really
really focuses on test scores
and test scores really really reward
intellectual like i one plus one is two
right
i know how this thing is put together
which then
tags autistic kids with wow this guy's a
genius
and it does two things one it takes a
kid who may not be great at math facts
but can walk in and sell something to
you know be a day trader or can read a
room and make their way through it and
it says that kid's dumb and he's not and
it also
says well your kid should be doing x y
and z because he can pass all these
tests and
there's the emotional regulation part
that's so heavy um
what are some ways and i'm not putting
you on the spot here i'm
i'm asking you this question because i
know i know it'll be a hard question to
answer but it's gonna be a gift to
the father's out there listening to this
what are some things you've tried
that you knew why you were trying them
weren't working
and you just kept hitting the gas harder
because you just because you're i'm out
of tools man
well for him in particular you know it's
it's a lot of times like chore list you
know i'll give him chores to do
and i know they won't be done by the
time i get home and i'll give him
consequences
for not getting them done and there's
just an excuse after
excuse and he never knows why you know
it's not my fault because of this
because of this and i keep telling him
in the real world your boss doesn't care
you know you're still going to get in
trouble you're still going to
and it just it's like talking to a brick
wall sometimes
yeah so the
frontal lobe development of a 16 year
old honestly can't process
in the real world when you're 26.
and that's the way i've done that i was
a high school basketball and track coach
i used that same line too
i used it with some of my 18 to 19 year
old college kids until i realized
they don't even know what that means
they can get it intellectually
but it doesn't wire the same way you and
i know if i don't go to work
my family doesn't eat right there's a
processing issue
um and that's not an excuse to not be a
participant
in this home you will do your chores and
i'm all about that too
so here's a couple things i've seen be
highly successful
going back to educating your son on
emotional
a reactivity of that has to do with do i
belong
and for the average 16 year old that's
the endless question
and all 16 year olds have weird teeth or
zits or they're too tall or too big or
too flat chested or two
whatever the thing is and so every 16
year old is scanning their environment
endlessly both in like both
you know with their thinking brain and
with their unconscious mind is scanning
the world do i fit in here do i belong
do i belong do i belong do i belong am i
too short am i too tall
not funny enough do i say enough bad
words do i say too many whatever
is giving him the understanding that he
belongs with you
and that he belongs at home so here's
a way to do that this may not solve all
of your problems but here's a way to do
it
you create with him you have other kids
too
i have a daughter who's 15 months older
than him yeah okay is she all in
yeah she's good she works three four
days a week she's
she's very different than him yeah okay
so i want you to get your kids is
mom live at home too uh me uh their mom
are separated okay
all right or divorced sorry okay okay um
and they live with you
yeah we go half and half every other
week half and okay
do you and do you and mom still
communicate yes
okay like can you all work together as a
team on some on things
most of the time yes okay so you add in
how long have you all been divorced
about ten years now
okay so you add in that additional i
don't belong anywhere now because i
belong everywhere
to an emotionally disregulated young man
and that becomes a lot does that make
sense that amplification
becomes intense and your daughter
might not be able to process it but she
can
feel it because she goes to mom's and
mom does her best to have a warm safe
place
that she can count on and she comes to
your house and there's a warm safe place
you can count on so she can
feel that she can regulate herself there
in that environment
your son can't and so creating a safe
place for him so here's what would be
beautiful
this is a this is perfect pie in the sky
world it may not work out this way
i would love to see a scenario where you
and your ex-wife
and the two kids create a here is the
rules of our family
here's who we're gonna be we don't even
live in the same house but here's who we
are and when i say rules now we do
chores
it's deeper than that we are a family
we're talking about identity we're a
family
who respects each other we're a family
who talks with respect to one another
we're a family who
is silly we're a family who is fun we're
a family who does our best to laugh
and then we're going to create behaviors
underneath these identities and i want
your kids to participate and if ex-wife
won't participate that's great
you do this for your home i want them to
participate
in who we're gonna be and bring them in
as vital members of this family you grew
up in the house of a marine i grew up in
the house of a homicide detective
and a swat hostage negotiator our homes
were what
our homes were going to be right and i
know my dad worked
i mean in ways that i will never fully
be able to
thank him for to shift and change as he
as he grew
just as a as a dad and a husband and a
man it's been incredible
but i get that home like this is what
discipline looks like and it came from a
great place there's just fewer tools in
the toolkit right
so you make sure those two kids sitting
around your table
and i've seen it done with artwork and
that's the way we do it in our house we
went to
like michael's or something like that
and we got a canvas
and we painted it at home with our
little kids here's who the delonies are
and then we could always point back to
that when it came to chores
because it wasn't a i told you to do
these things it was
hey this house doesn't run without you
we need
you are you okay are you hanging in
there because
this place is a three this has a
three-legged stool man and one of the
legs is just laying in the room
and what i've seen with young people is
they desperately want to know they
belong
they desperately want to know that
they're an integral part of a system
and they go to school they're told what
to do and they go to their fast food
jobs they're told what to do and they
read social media they're just told
they're losers and the world's falling
apart around them and they're all going
to die
and so they don't belong anywhere and so
in my house at my table you're going to
belong you know you do
and you're going to slowly shift your
language to your son with i know you're
brilliant how does it feel when
everybody's yelling at you in a language
you don't understand
and give him some um tools and it may be
that you all need to go sit down with an
aba
therapist right someone who's skilled at
working with autistic kids
we're going to learn some emotional
regulation tools so that he knows how to
because you're right he's going to have
to learn these skills
but i want him to learn these skills
tethered to
the anchor that dad says andrew belongs
because you're
mine and then from there this house
doesn't operate without you man
and then of course there's natural
consequences he's a 16 year old kid
so if he doesn't do these things hey you
opted out
of participation here i hate the fact
that you chose not to go to movies with
us on friday i
hate the fact that you chose not to go
to driver's ed or be able to drive
i don't know i i hate it because i
wanted you with us man but you opted out
and instead of i'm punishing you for
this
the results are the same they're still
gonna have consequences but i want them
to begin to internalize these
consequences not just try to please dad
does that make sense the shift there
it's subtle but it's massive
yeah i see what you're saying definitely
so this could be a
fun exercise for you just to think man
who are we as the andrew family
like who are we man and i'll tell you as
a dad it challenged me
because we put some things like we go on
adventures and you know what my
default setting is no my default setting
is dude let's just go to bed let's just
watch a movie
in one of our family core values and my
wife slid this in i knew
she tricked me we go on adventures does
that mean
we say yes and we actually turned one of
our family core values into we say yes
so when my son comes in at eight o'clock
at night and it's a weekend and said
hey instead of going for a movie can we
go on a night walk and try to catch
turtles
yep let's do it right we're just gonna
go on adventure we're going to make
memories that way
i had to change my behavior and it
became hard but then i got to model
to my kids what that looks like and they
got to participate in that
one other thing that i've seen just with
resounding success and i saw this with
college students i've talked about on
the show
i saw a partnership with a college
theater program
and the autism center
it's a research center but it worked
with college students with autism
and listening to these young people talk
about their experiences
they were side by side with theater
actors and
they didn't know how to process emotion
they didn't know how to process
pain they got angry right or they got
tensed up they didn't know how to
process fear they didn't know how to
process
social isolation but in a theater
context
they got to be an actor and inhabit
somebody else's body
and have it a character to which they
could be taught what pain was supposed
to look like
and what they learned from inhabiting
the body of other
characters was oh this is what this
could look like in me
and so it became less personal and it
became something you practice in a
theater context and i'll never forget
it's a
it's a goosebump moment going to watch a
theater performance
with world-class collegiate actors who
are theater
students and students with autism who've
been practicing for months with this
theater
troupe it was extraordinary and then
listening to the autistic students talk
about their experiences and how it's
impacted them
so i tell you this whether it's an
instrument whether it's playing in a
group whether it's joining a choir
whether it's joining a theater troupe
there is something powerful about art
that helps teach emotional regulation it
helps teach
processing it helps teaching you may not
be able to feel this but
what is that person suggesting
what is this songwriter what is this
song communicating to you does it feel
uplifting does it feel like the lights
are out they feel like the lights are on
and it gives young people with autism or
any young
person who's struggling with emotional
regulation or spoiler alert
grown-ups too it gives them a new
language
and it's profound right so i would
suggest getting with an aba
therapist there in your community if you
haven't already and then finding
an art troupe a theater troupe letting
them know that hey this one's gonna my
son's gonna have some some special needs
here
but begin to work with him but all that
tethers back to hey young man you belong
in my house and as a part of being in
this family
we can't function without you so here's
the the tasks you've got
on your plate here's a ta i got rent i
got food
i got going to work you got garbage man
and we can't do it without you right
love the call thank you so much andrew
you're stud i appreciate you ma'am
thanks to everybody who calls um thanks
for the letter writers thanks everybody
thanks to you guys
you guys being james and kelly i
realized somebody listening to the
podcast like who's he talking and we
don't say it enough but thanks to you as
well
and to let kelly speak for me as well
lots of as well
so as you wrap up today's show man i
met a bunch a couple of cool folks last
night
we're working on a project here that's
just incredible um
but one of the folks that we met her
name is lindsay said she's a big fan of
the show
and i told her you get to pick whatever
song the greatest song of all time and
we may have done this song i don't
remember it
but the song she picked made my heart
remember that scene in stepbrothers when
they look at each other and it's like
did we just become best friends
yep because she says um what about home
sweet home by motley crue
to which i wept large alligator tears
and said i'm married to my soul mate but
i think i just met a new friend it's off
the theater of pain album sometime
91 or something like that stop what
you're doing today and just listen to
this song
the piano intro tommy lee showing i'm
not just a drummer i'm a musician too
and it goes like this you know
i'm a dreamer but my heart's of gold i
had to run away high
so i wouldn't come home low and just
when things went right
doesn't mean they were always wrong just
take this song and you'll never
feel left all alone take me to your
heart
feel me on your bones just one more
night and i'm coming off this
long and winding road i'm on my way
i'm on my way home sweet home
tonight tonight i'm on my way
home sweet home i thought i knew what
that song meant for a long time after
reading that i have no idea what they're
talking about but we're just gonna roll
with it
right here on the dr john dolone show
[Music]